as Pavan said I'll primarily talk about
the ocean today and I'll talk about that
from a policy perspective in part and
from a conservation broadly of
biodiversity and ecosystem services
as well in the first part of the talk
I'll just give you a little bit of
background and then some specific
examples of work at CI with regard to
conservation of biodiversity and
ecosystem services and how that relates
to human well-being then I'm going to
spend a bit of time specifically talking
about work that I've done outside of CI
prior to joining CI two years ago on New
England Fisheries particularly
negotiating recovery plan for New
England Fisheries which I was the lead
on for a period of time and other people
have taken over when I left left
government to give you a specific
example of trying to implement policy to
if you like conserve an ecosystem
service that is food provisioning in a
highly developed region the the
northeast of the US the difficulties of
actually trying to implement that policy
but actually the results if you can
implement significant policy action so
with that this is a figure from my
colleague will Turner who leads one of
the teams within the science division at
CI looking at a global analysis of the
priority for biodiversity related to key
biodiversity areas on the x-axis and
ecosystem service value in normalized if
you like on the ordinate and what you
see is the the the black areas mean high
value high biodiversity priority in
other words key areas for conservation
of endemics and rare species which is
what key biodiversity areas are focused
on and of course amazon Andes region the
central Africa
part parts of Mexico and so on really if
you know the concept of mega diversity
countries the result is that the
ecosystem service value coincides high
ecosystem service value coincides with
areas of high or mega diversity and that
if you look at those areas in black that
also would coincide with the major
country programs for conservation
internationals so it gives you a sense
of where we work and why CI has a
partnership with IUCN International
Union for Conservation of Nature I'll
try to at least say the acronyms as
opposed to just speaking acronyms even
though I used to work for NOAA in the US
government which is known as the
National Organization for the
Advancement of acronyms it's probably
better if I actually spell out the the
terms in case you're not familiar with
them so this is analysis of red list
information from IUCN the red list
includes species in a number of
categories leading up to endangered that
are analyzed in a consistent methodology
across the globe and this was a summary
for the red list information that Mike
Hoffman and a very long list of authors
including me published last year the
only point I want to make is that well I
think you've seen a number of graphs
about biodiversity decline in the
Hoffman paper we also looked at what
would have happened the red line is what
would have happened without conservation
action so while there's still a decline
you see that in fact conservation action
can make a I would argue significant
difference when you look across the
entire red list data set in slowing that
decline hasn't by any means halted the
decline but there it is possible for
conservation action to slow the loss of
species red list pertains to loss of
species not just conservation actions in
general so it's a very particular slice
at this problem and that's useful to
motivate thinking about
whether in fact we're making any
difference at all no of course in the
literature over the last several years
there have been publications to the
contrary that have said really we see no
evidence of either the impact of
biodiversity on ecosystem services or
the impact of conservation actions but
if you again look at a detailed set of
data then you can see some impact from
conservation actions are you raising
your hand to house with and without yeah
yeah and feel free to interrupt so
that's fine in fact I'd rather you ask
me questions than by just droning on for
hours and hours so again the take the
take-home message is that conservation
action can actually have an impact on
even such dramatic patterns as decline
of biodiversity at least for some taxa
for amphibians that doesn't seem to be
the case so within the overall field of
conservation right now there's been an
increasing focus on ecosystem service in
support of human wellbeing as opposed to
simply the conservation of biodiversity
and in fact ci has changed its mission
from one of conservation of biodiversity
about three years ago the the alteration
in the mission was to conserve
biodiversity ecosystem services for its
impact on human wellbeing so this is a
simple graphic of our theory of change
which actually applies across lots of
organizations we take actions that we
hope will affect the health of
ecosystems however you like would like
to define health and you could do it in
a number of different ways just as you
would define human health in a number of
different ways but at least ostensibly
we would take a set of actions that
would conserve maintain or improve
ecosystem health we expect that will
have an impact on ecosystem services
which hence will have an impact on human
wellbeing again
the details of defining each of those
boxes is an interesting area that we're
currently working on in fact my group is
working on and testing different
approaches in Madagascar at the moment
there's an example here for freshwater
but of course it's most important to
look across a set of ecosystem services
not as not at each service individually
because they're not orthogonal they're
not at right angles to to one another
and it's also important to come up with
indicators in each of the boxes if you
like of the theory of change that's a
fairly concise set many of the the
studies that have talked about
indicators for ecosystem health have
come up with this enormous list you know
a hundred different things that you
should measure which in a policy context
actually isn't very useful for two
reasons one it's very difficult to
absorb and secondly because people will
choose the indicator that they prefer
and say well you know but in in my
context I'm doing extremely well because
we can see that the you know soil
nitrogen has increased and and that's
not very useful out of a very long list
of a hundred things on the other hand if
you can come up with five or six
indicators in each box perhaps a longer
list of ecosystem services then you get
a general sense of direction as opposed
to an extremely narrow evaluation of
ecosystem health and again think of the
human health analogy there's a few
indicators that tell medical doctors
where to look but they don't necessarily
tell everything so every time you have a
physical they do the same five things to
start the physical but then if they need
to explore deeper of course there's lots
of other tests that can be done having
that kind of a metric of whether in fact
we're making progress our actions have
had any impact is quite important in a
conservation context and you would think
that it would be a normal course of
business but in fact it isn't for lots
of reasons which we probably could
discuss for a while it hasn't been
case that people have consistently
measured conservation effectiveness for
ecosystems services in human wellbeing
and where while we and others are
working towards that end now it's
actually a pretty interesting area to
try to come up with the measures that
are responsive but not so highly
variable if they become meaningless nor
are they so stable that it doesn't
really make any difference because the
indicators never change its it and I'll
show you some examples at the end of the
talk on something called the ocean
health index that makes some steps in
this direction in addition to trying to
measure conservation effectiveness
there's also a need to actually set
priorities what are the areas that you
want to focus on we could say of course
every species is important every
ecosystem is important that's quite true
in some sense but it's not very helpful
for an organization like ours with a you
know reasonable but not extraordinary
budget well I guess that's a matter of
opinion the so it wouldn't be an
extraordinary budget to you it's about a
hundred and fifty million dollars a year
so the sort of normal course of things
no I you know it a hundred and fifty
million dollars a year for an
organization of a thousand people spread
a clock across the globe means that you
have to set some priorities so how do
you choose where to work well you choose
where to work based on your mission you
also want to choose where to work based
on that connection in the theory of
change in the previous slide where is
biodiversity ecosystems or ecosystem
health including biodiversity ecosystem
services and human wellbeing connected
in a focused way now in the past ci has
been very successful at utilizing
biodiversity hotspots concept as a way
of setting priorities and what we've now
begun to do quite extensively is is to
map ecosystem service values
particularly to populations in need a
shorthand here to the poor on to those
bio
versity hot spots to ask the question so
if you conserve biodiversity is that
sufficient to provide ecosystem service
value and the answer is often but not
entirely in two ways first of all there
are other areas that become important
for example for fresh water services
that are not strictly within a hotspot
construct most of the areas is covered
by biodiversity hotspots across the
tropical developing world where we work
but there are other areas that become
important there were also other areas
that are quite important for things such
as carbon sequestration and climate
regulation such as agricultural lands
which may not be a focus for
biodiversity hotspots the second way
that the picture becomes modified is if
you set your priorities based on a
single ecosystem service and I don't
have a specific slide of this so you'll
have to hopefully follow the arguments
and I can refer you to a paper by Frank
Larson for my group if you set your
priorities based on a single service
like carbon sequestration and then
another service fresh water service
provision or biodiversity what you find
is that if you set them solely on say
biodiversity then you don't do a very
good job of meeting all of your other
goals on the other hand if you back off
on the biodiversity goal slightly and
you also include considerations for
carbon in fresh water for example you
find that you will get 90% of the
biodiversity conservation value in your
priorities but you'll get a much higher
percentage of the other two and so
there's some trade-off analyses to be
done on how you set priorities when you
look in an ecosystem service context now
that becomes important in a given
landscape because I think we have
assumed for a long time that as long as
you were concerned conserving the
biodiversity really had covered the
other aspects with regard to things such
as carbon sequestration and
fresh water food provisioning and so on
and that turns out not to be exactly
true it's close but it's not exactly
true and so you need to modify the
priority setting to actually incorporate
multiple services and you get a
different result it's not drastically
different but it's importantly different
hopefully that was intelligible and
again Frank Larson published that
trade-off analysis yes
so this is realized services in other
words available but doesn't necessarily
deal with all of the access issues and
is not evaluation based on payment for
ecosystem services strictly it's access
of those services to the poor for a set
of services and lists and in this case
you know there's climate reserves flood
management freshwater provisioning to
populations in need so it's basically
localizing populations in need and
saying this service becomes available as
opposed to how much would they pay for
it the value of the service is is a
broader what do we believe a cubic meter
of water in this locale is worth not the
value of the service to the poor people
you see the distinction yep
yeah
so the not very in in this global
analysis it's not particularly
fine-grained it's really quite coarse
the challenge of doing this and the
previous work is do you have something
that's scalable such that you could
actually apply the concept at a
landscape level up to a country level or
even a regional level and you could set
your priorities from a from a landscape
level to a to a country level up to a
regional level and to do that you're
likely going to start with the course
data but as you try to downscale to a
landscape level you'll run into some
data problems so then the question is
how robust is the result so that's you
know what an analogue to that is trying
to downscale climate impact or climate
effects from the global models the
difference here is that you'd need to do
more than the physics so you've got much
higher dimensionality than in a climate
model but still you don't have very good
fine scale data in some locations what
you then do is you try to base it off
the global data sets and then ground
truth it with selected foreign skill
data so they didn't get to the landscape
level but again it's it's ecosystem
service value in general delivered to an
area where there's a high concentration
of people in poverty to get back to the
previous question and if I forget to
look to the left then somebody shout out
at me I don't mind I am a former
regulator I'm used to being yelled at so
now let me talk about ocean ocean issues
a little bit and generally if you ask
even a fairly broad audience so what
what do you get from the ocean you'll
get two things and even if if somebody
had a vague idea of what ecosystem
services were one of them is you get
fish so food and the other one
recreation
and beyond that probably you wouldn't
hear very much you know a lot of people
like to be near the ocean for
recreational reasons and actually
fisheries are an incredibly important
source of high quality protein even if
the tonnage is not nearly the same as
agricultural tonnage and incidentally
tend to have a much lower ecological
footprint than any other form of food
provisioning or almost any other form
any other major form of food
provisioning I suppose that we should
include wild gathering as well but in
fact lots of other things come from the
ocean including climate regulation
shoreline protection and so on and
certainly waste disposal and so on so
it's it's pretty clear that while we
tend to think of terrestrial sources for
providing many of the ecosystem services
even in the millennium ecosystem sense
which I know you're all familiar with
many of those same services at least a
portion of them come from ocean
ecosystems and sometimes a very
significant portion certainly climate
regulation you would have to argue is
probably dominated by the ocean at least
as a heat sink as well as in terms of
carbon food provisioning it depends but
certainly for high quality protein
obviously a number of other recreational
services are incredibly important I'm
not including hear things like mineral
extraction or shipping which are not
really ecosystem services I guess
driving a ship over the surface of the
ocean is a service in some sense was dry
it wouldn't happen but I'm not really
thinking of that as an ecosystem service
on the other hand in some cases there
are is a serious trade-off to be
considered with regard to getting goods
to land through a port which has impacts
on ecosystems and in some sense as a
trade-off with a set of services that's
not going to advance from the mouse
it's also fairly clear that in most
cases we have treated ocean in coastal
area as much as we've treated many of
the land areas that is we've used an
exploit ativ model that says here's just
a resource to be used
there's many famous quotes about ocean
resources being inexhaustible I'm often
attributed attributed probably unfairly
to Huxley you know you could never
possibly over exploit fish stocks
because the ocean is too big which has
turned out to be almost completely
untrue I can't think of any resource
that that would be true for but also
coastal development itself has had a
huge impact on the services an ocean can
provide in the health of coasts itself
and so one of the challenges is can we
come up with an approach to utilizing
ocean areas that is sustainable as
opposed to unsustainable because many of
the practices we currently use are
unsustainable how many of you have been
to the Mediterranean sometime in the
last ten years
it's a spectacularly beautiful empty
ocean fisheries mesh size there's a big
art has been a big argument over whether
it should be 30 millimeters or 40
millimeters for trawl nets in the
Mediterranean you've got an armored
Coast in a lot of areas very strange
nutrient dynamics you've got a few areas
that are still healthy it's been
exploited for a really long time as have
other areas but it it's in some sense a
poster child for unsustainable
exploitation of ocean and coastal
resources and not the only one so we
certainly have plenty of experience in
an unsustainable development model for
ocean areas now that doesn't mean that
the Mediterranean no longer provides any
services it doesn't mean that it's ugly
it doesn't mean even that no Fisheries
occur there even though most of what you
get out of there is about that big
with a few exceptions but it means that
you've lost a huge amount of the
ecosystem service in there for the
ecosystem service value but most people
think it's a pretty spectacular place to
go vacation or to live or to work on how
come I mean if it's lost so much value
why aren't people going yeah it's not
just because it's sunny and warm and you
know the French and Italians know how to
cook
I guess the Spanish - they're the you
know there are other reasons well
they're still his ecosystem services
there and many of them are quite
extraordinary but there was a huge
reservoir to deplete if you like over
you know a couple of thousand years at
least so we should be careful to imagine
that it's sort of an on/off switch that
the services go away even in the
Mediterranean there's relatively few
marine species that have gone extinct
although some have it's likely that many
of the shark species or will have or
will completely disappear for example
but it's not gone it's just severely
depleted and that raises the question
could you get back to a sustainable
development path well that's an
interesting question I mean I think
you've had earlier lectures that have
talked about switching between States
and the difficult so-called
nonlinearities between states of the of
an ecosystem and the difficulty of
recovering back to another state
sometimes that seems to be possible
sometimes not what is often the
observation is even if you can recover
an ecosystem ocean ecosystem or
terrestrial that the state that you
recover to was not the original state
you it's an unpredictable it's
unpredictable where you'll land and so
this is not just true in the
Mediterranean it's true in many many
other areas for her oceans if we you
take a simple look at coral ecosystems
even in western Pacific relatively
lightly exploited near developed Islands
you see a relatively depleted coral with
not a lot of fish although some
as you move up a gradient to relatively
remote or extremely remote in some cases
I think this is Palmyra where there
aren't any people then you see a very
different ecosystem a much more robust
set of corals now lots of large
predatory fishes or in fact instead of
just a complete food web which we often
think of as a pyramid in these in places
like Palmyra where you have an inverted
pyramid where most of the biomass is
actually at the top top levels of a food
web which means a couple of things I
mean it it it relates to spatial scale
and temporal scale spatial scale because
there's lots of migration in temporal
scale because very long live creatures
are can be supported at a high biomass
level as long as they're supported by
relatively high turnover it also turns
out that these kinds of ecosystems are
much more resilient to things such as
coral bleaching events climate change
impacts more broadly and certainly other
impacts including some fishing than
these kinds of systems and again even
this system if you compared it to the
Caribbean is lightly impacted or you
compare it to the Mediterranean for
example it would be lightly impacted so
we do know that there are really
significant differences between impacted
systems and unimpacted systems it
doesn't mean that it's feasible to have
a remote fully functioning ecosystem in
all locales but you need to recognize
that gradient and the fact that it's
almost certainly nonlinear so one of the
programs that Conservation International
has worked on for the last five years is
called the marine man Asterius science
program ma yeah ma s and what we did is
try to establish effectively zoning
approaches in four principal areas
western one in in Fiji one of Brazil one
in Belize and another in kalapa goes and
then compare
to as many other studies that we could
find of marine protected areas or zoned
areas around the world across the
tropics in areas that supported coral
reefs so we actually had a conservation
program in those four areas and compared
it with as many other data sets as
possible around the globe and the goal
was not to simply create protected areas
but to create a gradient from fully
protected to open access with some other
options in between and so in Belize
here's two years of comparing fish
biomass inside and outside a managed
area with higher biomass inside a
managed area as opposed to an open
access area which is a fairly
predictable result you will have seen
some of these graphs from people at
Calum Roberts certainly Steve gains than
Halpern and others before and so it's
now a well-known result no big surprise
this is my short course in population
dynamics for all of you who haven't
studied populations a minute dynamics
before if you don't kill the animals
they don't die so fast so that's what
that says
now you know all there is to know about
population dynamics and can move on you
know if you protect an area and in fact
there's a significant biomass of fish in
the area it's relatively important then
you can expect that they will that
higher biomass either will be conserved
within the area or may grow
substantially because the fish and other
creatures are allowed to allow to grow
within within that area now that works
really well when things stay in one
place and it but it can still work even
for migratory species as long as the
vulnerability within that area is high
you've protected them for a portion
where that vulnerability can't be made
up outside the area or another way to
put that is the area's large enough such
this is a significant fraction of
protection inside and a protected area
the principle of you know marine managed
areas is the same as you would have in a
terrestrial environment and in fact you
know I mean I once had somebody say to
me you know
you can't possibly know how many fish
there are in the sea unless you can
count them exactly like you count trees
in the forest to which I replied that's
true fish are exactly like trees except
you can't see them and they move so
they're pretty easy to count in other
words things are going to move in and
out of these areas in a much different
way than a protected Park they're there
and your ability to measure these things
is going to be much less than of course
in a terrestrial environment but we've
now established the principle that for
sizing and sighting of protected areas
in many places and we know that in fact
you'll get high bio bio Mouse in for at
least many of the species here's another
example from Brazil where now you have a
gradient from you know relatively long
established no-take marine reserves to
relatively new multiple access areas
incomplete over open access
you might ask so wide open access areas
increase here and then decrease as well
well because protected areas do two
things because things move unlike trees
one of them is you increase the biomass
in the area the second is they seed
outside the area so they provide a
refuge that allows for movement outside
the area and you might actually increase
biomass outside the area for a short
period of time the problem is its
short-lived because then targeting or
exploitation of that biomass can happen
very rapidly but we get a consistent
pattern of improvement based on
protected areas I guess they're and so
you'll see higher density our fish
biomass increased species etc I suppose
the question is so what I mean why is it
important to have a lot more fish in a
protected area anybody you want to tell
me why because I can't figure it out no
I mean why would you why does it matter
that you've just increased biomass it's
a nice thing I mean we like fish we'd
like them to live longer but there's
must must be some reason beyond that did
you want to ask a question and you want
to answer mine
okay it's easier than measuring
biodiversity why do we care that there's
more biodiversity okay and in fact you
saw an example of that from Yvonne's
lecture I think in an earlier at the
beginning of the course for New England
the area I'm going to talk about in a
minute of there's a lot of migration
outside but fundamentally that biomass
if it becomes utilized supports human
wellbeing or if it becomes and it can be
utilized in lots of different ways that
utilization could be the biomass
provides for greater nutrient cycling it
could be because people get to eat it it
could be because it supports recreation
but we're making an assumption in many
cases that more biomass or more
biodiversity actually goes to improve
human wellbeing remember that theory of
change so we're trying to move beyond
now simply saying well you know we'd
like the fish to live longer because we
like fish they're very pretty they are
providing some kind of ecosystem service
and we believe that those services are
important for human well-being not just
because you can eat fish and so then the
question becomes if you encourage people
in a local community to establish a
marine managed area as we did in this
study do they see any benefit or are
they just you know now they live in a
poor community on the coast of Brazil
but they can feel like they've made an
important contribution to conservation
on the planet no they would actually
just like people anywhere else like to
see you know more options for employment
this thing works greater income and so
on inside a managed area versus outside
of managed area so again we need to
validate that theory of change that in
fact the improvement in services results
in a real improvement in human wellbeing
and those measures tend to be income
health and stability of a community
so on you know in this I don't know
where that picture is from the CI is
really good at putting pictures that
don't necessarily relate to the graph
but let's assume this is one of the
Marine managed areas I don't happen to
know where that one is from but did have
an opportunity to visit the area where
Brazil the abroad area of Brazil where
we had established one of the sites for
the marine managed areas program and in
fact the protected areas both fully
protected and partial use areas had been
in place for ten years and the village
then was able to obtain electricity
because of higher income they were able
to do something different with their
schools because of higher income as well
as livelihoods and income opportunities
for people within the village it's a
pretty interesting place because it was
a small island across a narrow creek
they had made a decision as a village
not to allow any motorized vehicles on
the island but they still and they had
obtained from the government the
opportunity to establish reserves where
they had exclusive rights of access to
certain portions of the area so they
actually had some ownership and when I
was there they were celebrating a
10-year anniversary of establishing the
reserve and the things that it brought
into that village so there is a direct
connection to what happens to people in
communities or and sometimes a direct
connection into broader set of ecosystem
services things like climate mitigation
may or may not bring direct benefits
locally it depends on how they're
structured fisheries tend to be much
more locally focused
oops
did I go the wrong way so to go back to
the idea of priority setting then you
need to do the same thing in the oceans
what are the most diverse areas where
they impacted and where are the most
vulnerable human populations comes a
little bit more difficult in the ocean
but effectively we're evaluating
biodiversity threats and high-value
habitats in the same way as we do
terrestrially it's just the oceans a
really really big place and the data is
even
than it is on land so you can in fact
map biodiversity in terms of species
richness problem you can use other
diversity measures but richness is
probably a reasonable starting point in
many cases there are some analyses I'll
show you of threats and then value of
habitats and for ecosystem services
so from IUCN data and from things like
the census of marine life you can obtain
marine biodiversity data to measure
richness you can also look at species
endemism places that are particular for
individual species for conservation of
both local and global biodiversity so
there's a number of different ways to
get it this question of where are the
places where you have the highest degree
of endemic species looking at drivers of
change is again there are global data
sets it's quite difficult than Halpern
and Company and the next slide have
compiled a broad set of impacts in a
paper in 2008 that has tried to say
where are the impacts most intense where
do they overlay with one another one
another on a global basis and now have
in the last three years have now
downscaled those analyses to look at
particular impacts in particular marine
ecosystems although I'm not showing you
those slides so for example they've done
an analysis of the Mediterranean that
should come out fairly soon that looks
at what are the principal impacts in
different portions of the Mediterranean
from shipping to fishing to pollution
climate you know warming temperatures
and the like a couple of things come out
from the global analysis one is there
really aren't or there are hardly any
places that have low impact from human
activities and secondly the intensity of
that impact is more or less as you would
expect but there's some surprises such
as you know in the middle of the Pacific
is very intense
okay that
there's some very intense impacts which
can be due to things like ocean
circulation patterns so you yep
don't think so
I think it's a it's both first of all we
don't know that much about deep-sea
species so we're still looking primarily
in photic zone and some some additions
and secondly productivity is highest
near the coasts so you would expect in
some sense higher number of species
because you get higher niche separation
and all of that in a higher but of
course you have higher diversity on
western you know in western boundary
current sorry eastern boundary current
areas than western boundary current
areas and there's some other patterns
like that high diversity in the tropics
but it is a common some of it is data
lack just because of the deep sea is so
poorly known and probably will continue
to be for some time because it's very
very hard to get significant funding for
a lot of deep-sea work if you included
microbial diversity then of course these
numbers are gigantic
but there's relatively little known
about microbial diversity in the in
ocean waters so the real question is how
do you how do you put the two together
biodiversity and the impacts it's not
just biodiversity for your priority
setting it's also impacts what's the
overlay between them and then and you
can do that exactly that analyses and
again we find that the areas where you
have high rarity and high impact as well
as those areas that have high richest
and low impact tend to be the places
that we see I work across the tropics so
although we don't happen to work in the
Caribbean very much which is a high
impact area but we do work on the coast
of South America we have intensive
marine work in Southeast Asia and the
Pacific seascape there are important
areas in Galapagos of course and some in
along the coast of Colombia these areas
are relatively poorly known in part for
marine species so that's probably not a
very good representation of Africa it's
not that they're low impacted or have no
diverse
they're just not as well known as the
other areas and if we actually wanted as
we do want to want to end up with a
priority setting mechanism then we want
to look at a range of well how those
that overlay of biodiversity and impacts
relate to some measures of human
dependence on those resources whether it
be Human Development Index or dietary
proportion of dietary animal protein
from marine resources which is that one
you could probably read it better than I
do because I don't have glasses on and
so on so that's how we are trying to
construct a priority setting mechanism
for the oceans and again it needs to be
scalable down to if you like a seascape
level because the global analysis just
tells you well the areas that you're
already focusing on generally are the
right ones that's no big surprise but if
you can scale it down now to an
ecosystem level or a large marine
ecosystem level it becomes much more
interesting okay let me turn to
fisheries the we used to court I'm
actually trained as a fishery biologist
I'm probably the only one you will ever
meet the we used to in the fisheries
community called you know working in
fisheries was referred to as picking up
the wrong pamphlet at the career
counselors door it's tends to be very
contentious I want to use it as an
example of really a sectoral approach to
trying to implement conservation actions
with the conservation and management
actions conservation actions however you
want to phrase that so this is a
combination of world capture fisheries
and aquaculture production from FAO
I think you might have seen this before
the dark blue is including China the
lighter blue is excluding China anybody
happen to know why these are separated
out in this way anybody read this paper
why why would we separate out China two
reasons
somebody make a guess please excuse
commit many other places gigantic
aquaculture production increases in
production boys I know what this is just
actually capture fisheries and
aquaculture production so there was some
there were real questions about
particularly the capture fishery
statistics from China a few years ago
and this is not particularly you know
taking cheap shots at China but it a
colleague of mine daniel pauly at
university of british columbia looked at
the FAO statistics and said Wow
China's producing an awful lot of
capture fisheries how can that be and it
turned out that the the statistics are
compiled on a country basis by FAO and
the country reports for China were based
on production for regions and the reward
for the people who were reporting the
statistics was based on how much
production they had reported and so he
did some ecosystem analyses from one of
his modeling methods called eco path and
said it doesn't actually appear that
those ecosystems could produce anything
like that amount of fish and it turned
out that there was substantial
misreporting of the statistics because
the incentive was to report very high
numbers because that's how you were
rewarded and it only really shows up for
China now if anyone in the room believes
that that only happens in China then I
you know would like to sell you some
property but you know so it happens
almost everywhere but because China is
so big it has a dramatic effect on the
statistics yes
lightning-like I just want to add a
little story from my own experience and
once my senior economist of Deutsche
Bank in Singapore pointed out to me that
have you seen the latest Chinese state
wise GDP statistics I said no he showed
me his list of numbers and he says by
the way these numbers are all higher
than 90% and for information the
official GDP growth in China is eight
point five missile but all the states
are above the average just a little bit
like Garrison Keillor all your children
was above average yes this is actually
this one is corrected and originally
world capture fisheries continued to
increase and what's happened is instead
actually aquaculture production has
increased very dramatically in China and
while capture fisheries have leveled off
I think I didn't put in the capture
fishery alone so this is is a corrected
graph because capture fisheries are
about 80 to 90 million metric tons a
year and the remain remainder is
aquaculture actually this year because
this only goes up to 2002 this this
current year is the first year where
aquaculture production is probably
equalled capture fisheries so this is a
corrected graph but since then people
have tended to separate out the Chinese
statistics now in this case it's because
of the aquaculture growth but there's a
very this is a problem again globally in
reporting statistics what's the
incentive for any place you know again
this is not just because China is the
only place that's misreporting it's very
broadly the case it's very hard to get
production numbers that would be true in
agriculture would being true in lots of
other other settings for many countries
just out of curiosity so this is a
slightly odd pattern right here anybody
want to guess what that little dip is
it's actually real come on somebody must
be able to guess this is the Yale School
of Forestry give me a break yep
flood in 1998 no it's not although
that's a pretty good it's related to
that yeah L mean oh yeah so why would L
Nino have such a big impact on in this
case capture fishery production because
the largest fish catch in the world is
Peruvian anchovy de and when an El Nino
occurs Peruvian anchovy doe doesn't do
very well because there's a switching
behavior with sardine but it moves
further offshore and production is much
lower and actually can be seen in global
statistics when you have a severe El
Nino which also was of course the reason
for the floods so that's why it's
related so now you have about 50% of the
production from aquaculture and 50% from
capture fisheries and some people
believe that will ultimately end up with
aquaculture only only problem with that
is that most aquaculture many types of
species that are cultured actually
depend on wild production so the other
problem with that is the ocean is 70% of
the planet you know that's an awful lot
of aquaculture production so it's not
quite the same as land conversion for
agriculture and capture fisheries are
probably gonna be around for quite a
while again 80 to 90 million metric tons
is about the world fish catch and in
fact it's been flat for the last decade
now that's not because people are no
longer concerned about catching fish nor
is it because people have been backing
off substantially on effort it means we
no longer finding new fisheries to
continue the increase that happened
since the 1950s you can no longer
compensate by finding new resources to
exploit to keep the growth going as
other resources are either leveled out
or depleted which is quite important it
means that we can't rely on very much
more ocean production other than
increases in aquaculture production as a
food security issue I used to work with
a guy named John goand I shouldn't tell
too many stories because I'm going to
long but he used to work with a guy
named John going to was at FAO in the
1960s and 1970s
and a lot of people were trying to
estimate what would be the ultimate
world fish catch and he said 80 to 90
million metric tons the other estimates
were 300 million metric tons 500 million
metric tons we'll just take all the
Crayola of Antarctica and so on and you
know 30 years before we reached the peak
he got it pretty much right he was also
the only guy I ever saw who could chair
an international meeting fall deeply
asleep on the first day wake up on the
last day and accurately summarized the
meeting but he got it right
at about 80 to 90 million metric tons
okay so I'm not going to go into a long
discussion of fishing and overfishing
but sorry go ahead
no I think they probably will remain if
in fact we do a good job of management
they could be some slight increases but
they will remain within the range of 80
to 90 million metric tons aquaculture
will continue to increase prices Oh
almost certainly it means that prices
will continue to rise and of course in
many places fish is no longer a
commodity product it's a luxury product
certainly in the u.s. I'm sorry I didn't
hear the question
so fisheries again as a sectoral example
in some ways is a bit different from
other ecosystem services because we have
a fairly well-developed theory about how
the populations work so this is the
slightly longer course in population
dynamics fish populations compensate for
increased mortality or fishing pressure
represented by fishing rate which
increases to the left and that
compensation in their population
dynamics allows for higher reproduction
higher growth rates which allows for
more yield that comes to a maximum at a
particular exploitation rate so at some
point when you're removing some fraction
of the of a individual population or if
you like an aggregate of populations it
achieves some maximum usually referred
to as maximum sustainable yield in at
least an equilibrium or stationary model
and if you exceed that fishing rate you
would expect the population or
populations to decline
well most ecosystem services don't have
a simple generating function so while we
know what the you know what might be a
reference point for fisheries maximum
sustainable yield and we might know one
for climate because we have global
climate models that and we've said we
don't want more than a certain degree
temperature rise globally we don't have
the same kind of reference points for
nutrient cycling or storm protection or
climate adaptation in the whole set of
ecosystem services that you would see in
the millennium ecosystem sense but in
fisheries we do so that means we kind of
know what we need to do you don't want
the exploitation rate the proportion of
the stock that you remove every year due
to fishing to exceed a particular look
level because if you do the stock will
decline in other words it's pretty
simple we know what we need to do
control a fishing rate therefore the
populations will be maintained there's
other factors habitat and so on which
obviously are going to in the past at
least have related mostly to fishing
rate although sometimes to other kinds
of activities so in a sectoral basis
this should be quite simple to manage
this is a too complicated graph that
relates to using different management
measures but but the point I want to
make is that if you looked at maximum
sustainable yield for this graph which
happens to be modeled on Cod it would
probably be over here but the act
maximum long-term economic yield will
always be at a lower fishing rate and
that's a fairly general result for most
fisheries certainly most fisheries
models that's been around for quite a
while so in order to get the greatest
economic return on a sustainable basis
you have to fish even less than you
would a maximum sustainable yield rate
and that's not just because of
stochasticity or variability in the
population it's because of the economics
of fisheries to try it and so you will
obtain more in the long term at a lower
harvest rate well there's a lot of press
stories that say you know most Fisheries
in the world are collapsing that turns
out actually compared to a reference
level of maximum sustainable yield not
to be true
roughly 28 to 30 percent of the stocks
in the world that are measured by FAO
again are considered to be over
exploited roughly 60 percent of the
stocks are either overexploited or fully
exploited in other words we wouldn't
expect them to yield any more and then
the remainder potentially could be
exploited slightly higher but you
wouldn't get a huge amount of additional
yield out of that that's why we're still
in the 80 to 90 million metric ton range
so when people say all the stocks are
overexploited at least for the present
period that's not true historically
that's a different question compared to
what happened 100 years ago and I'll
just
in a minute so it's important to keep
that figure in mind at least management
wise there's a significant fraction of
stocks about 28% that are overexploited
and then many more that are managed
around the reference point again we kind
of know what to do and in some cases
we've done it is the summary of that
internationally fisheries are well
within 200 miles of every coastal state
under the law of the sea there's an
exclusive economic zone which means that
that coastal state has exclusive right
to those fisheries resources to do with
as they like now they've signed on in
the law of the sea and something called
the UN fish stocks agreement to try to
utilize to not over exploit to
sustainably manage their fish stocks in
their national zones as well as outside
around a maximum sustainable yield level
so what happens outside of 200 miles
well they're on the high seas again the
UN fish stocks agreement which was
negotiated in 1995 pertains and it says
we should try to maintain those stocks
on the high seas at a level that will at
least produce yeah that should produce
maximum sustainable yield in other words
not over exploit them well how does that
work because there's no international
jurisdiction and it effectively works by
treaty agreements and regional fishery
management organizations and these are
some of them that are are listed here
each are established by a separate
treaty each have member states and the
rules that they come up with are
dependent upon how the member states
behave in other words what they agree to
I was actually the US delegate for this
one and I've had some work with Kamel R
which is the Antarctic one and with Ike
at the Commission for conservation of
Atlantic tunas and for a couple of
others that I didn't list they're like
the salmon convention and so on and
basically what happens is that the
member states get into a room
and each argue on behalf of their share
of the fishery for their state generally
the delegations are heavily industry
focused and each if you like coastal
state or member state then argues for
their largest share of the quota they
can get and so what happens when you
have to reduce the fishing pressure well
the easiest thing to do if you're trying
to decide who gets it you know what
piece of the pie is to first agree that
the pie is bigger than you thought
because then everybody gets a little bit
bigger bigger piece and so the history
of many of the organization's is in fact
that they've allowed over exploitation
on the high seas that's slowly changing
probably International Commission for
conservation of Atlantic tunas is the
poster child for how to do this badly
with particularly over-exploitation of
bluefin tuna which is highly vulnerable
in some other species but there are
rules it's just how the coastal states
behave in those four because the
decisions are based on those member
states in each of the Commission's and
there are rules then on every state
controlling its vessels wherever they
fish and so on now it's under
international law so it's very
imperfectly enforced there is an
international standard on the fish
stocks agreement and then there were a
whole set of bilateral agreements so it
is not that it's anything goes on the
high seas it's just very difficult to
agree in international areas that people
should take responsible action with
regard to their industry compared to
other industries and you know it's an
interesting thing to do although
passingly strange to be in these
negotiations because you know they
generally are elaborate games of you
know you show me your cards then I'll
show you mine so you kind of sit there
all night until finally in the morning
when everybody's too tired you make some
kind of an agreement to not over exploit
quite as much as you used to
and and then everybody goes home and
congratu
each other and then you do it again the
next year so it's gotten a lot better
but it's still a really difficult
process we know that over that
overexploiting fish stocks first of all
it has occurred
it does have ecosystem level effects so
it doesn't matter just for the cod or
for the tuna it has much broader set of
effects this is from a National Academy
study from a few years ago Pavan showed
you a picture from again from daniel
pauly on fishing down food webs in other
words cropping off from the top many
other kinds of patterns occur that you
see in a food web sense throughout
throughout an ecosystem and if we look
historically and this is for some work
that I did with colleagues in New
Hampshire in this happens to be on the
Scotian shelf we know that we've very
severely depleted many ecosystems
including the Northeast North East shelf
from historical levels so here's a
biomass estimate from the 1850s based on
actually really good data and there's
currently where the biomass is for
Scotian shelf cod stocks and the
sustainable yield as estimated by the
canadians would be probably about there
well compared to 1 2.2 million metric
tons of biomass in the 1850s that's a
pretty big change so this is definitely
an altered ecosystem that's the average
size 6 pounds that was the average size
in the 1850s and so we know that these
are altered ecosystems much like an
agricultural ecosystem is altered due to
exploitation does anyone think we would
get back to 1.2 million metric tons no
on the other hand does the system have
much greater capacity to produce a
service in other words food even on a
sustainable basis absolutely I'm gonna
skip the next one here's an example from
the coast of Maine to bring it to people
so in 1861 223 sailing vessels before
the Dory fishery so they were fishing
over the side of schooners fishing in
the Gulf of Maine caught 12,000 metric
tons of fish the mechanized fleet in the
Gulf of Maine in 2007 called
3,000 tons
so we've again reduced the availability
of that service just in terms of food
provisioning now this was not an
unexploited ecosystem in 18 in 1861 had
already been exploited for 200 years
so we've fundamentally changed the the
productivity of these systems it may
change back it's unclear how far back
you can go so now let me talk about
recent management for fisheries I know
I'm running a little long but that's too
bad I'm standing up here and you just
have to vote with your feet this is the
recent history of landings for US
fisheries for so-called ground fish cod
haddock yellowtail flounder Pollock 1919
stocks and the ground fish complex but
these three cod haddock and yellowtail
flounder being the primary ones sent
from 1960 into the to the end of the
century and the vertical lines are
different stances of management first
international quotas voluntary quotas
then under 200-mile extended
jurisdiction under the law of the sea
and actually US unilaterally declared
200-mile limit a year before it was
agreed internationally and then several
other plans which resulted in a decline
a decline a short blip and a long
decline in landings this is not biomass
if you looked at biomass you'd see much
the same thing it was mirroring landings
at that time down to really a cod
fishery with not much in it in the
mid-90s so you might ask the question so
what the heck was all that management
stuff if that's the result of trying to
manage and for natural capital for
ecosystem service if you like for a
single sector this is just managing the
fishery could be that lots of other
things were happening this is over
exploitation in 1990 the exploitation
rate was about 66 percent of the
standing stock every year of haddock was
removed the sustainable rate was about
20 percent and we were arguing bitterly
at the time
that weather the sustainable rate was
you know 20% or 25% what difference does
it make you're harvesting 66% so doesn't
really matter but you couldn't actually
move forward in management until that
argument was settled believe it or not
for COD again here's the the blue line
is the spawning stock that's where it
should have been this is the red line is
the exploitation rate that's where it
should have been people said well why is
the stock continuing to decline because
simply if you went back to that other
graph you're over exploiting it there
was no mystery it was a fairly simple
result and in fact for 20 years the
scientific advice was you're over
exploiting the stock and it will decline
and that turned out to be correct even
though it was disputed every year and is
still disputed every year since but
fundamentally the population dynamics
was simple you were killing them too
fast so they died that's the same
picture so what happens in these things
in a policy setting it's my favorite
kind of data cuz I just made it up so
suppose this is the status of the
resource it's going down due to over
exploitation and you've got some science
warnings in the pink line that keeps
saying you know it's getting really bit
you're really over exploiting I used to
be before I was the manager for this
fish the fishery in the Northeast I was
the guy going to the management councils
and delivering the science advice and I
used to call my job a thousand ways to
say you're killing too many fish so many
fish are dying you know the exploitation
rate is too high you know the
exploitation pattern is wrong you can
say it a thousand ways basically you
were killing too many fish and the
warnings continue to go up and as they
do the political resistance goes up and
therefore the stock continues to go down
because the management response is to
that political resistance you know as as
the so here's a little blip in the
status of the resource in the middle
well that's taken by man you know that's
taken by political responses aha the
science was all wrong
which means management backs way off
therefore the resource declines even
more quickly so you can sort of trace
through the sets of of advice or in the
response so why is management backing
off well because where does that
political resistance come from probably
none of you were writing or your parents
were writing to your Congressman saying
I'm really worried about fisheries but
you can bet that a lot of fishermen were
so why are they resisting something that
might stop that resource decline
it's not because they don't understand
it it's not because they're bad people
it's because it's going to have an
immediate impact on them and there isn't
any means of them to be to step aside
for a few years from their livelihood
there's no alternative livelihood that's
anywhere near what they can earn in
fisheries so the result of that I will
be the only lecture on this course who
has ever been hung in effigy that's me
up there that's my colleague Pat Kirk Oh
being hung on the other side this is a
demonstration in Gloucester Harbor where
I live against rules to restrict the
fishery and along the front are
representatives from each of the elected
officials offices saying the poor
fisherman you really shouldn't implement
these rules too because they will be
impacted and by the way nobody else is
watching or is going to change their
vote because of fishery rules so that
political resistance is intense on the
people are approximately affected by any
set of regulations and it's not a
surprise it's not anything that you
wouldn't expect to happen but it's very
difficult to work through which is why
you had all those management stanzas
that really had no effect because if you
want to succumb to the political
resistance take a big action that has no
effect works really well so in nineteen
end of nineteen ninety-four I became the
manager the so-called Northeast Regional
Administrator for fisheries the second
week on the job was closing these three
areas on Georges Bank a year later that
one was a very popular guy
it's about 8,000 square miles of the
ocean to at least begin to halt to that
over-exploitation pattern and here's the
result I have to show this graph no
matter what I'm talking about whether
it's fisheries or anything else so
there's the abundance of cod haddock and
yellowtail flounder I became Regional
Administrator there which was the
implementation of amendment five and
thereafter the stocks got better so
that's why I have to show the graph
every time now this wasn't me
implementing it obviously there's a it's
finally coming to the point where you
can get enough political backing so that
I was allowed to do what was pretty
blindingly obvious stopover exploiting
to see if you can turn the stock around
so there was no mystery about it it
wasn't like I just thought this up and
nobody had ever thought of it before
that we really shouldn't hammer this
thing into the ground it's you had a a
enough convergence of political forces
such that you could actually implement
what was needed to conserve the natural
capital and rebuild particularly the
haddock resource and I'll skip on to
well same thing for the aggregate
biomass across the 19 stocks in the
ground fish complex so it overall
recover even though haddock was the most
dramatic interesting quote from my
colleague John Brodie ACK it was the
first time since the early 1900's that
the stock hadn't been over exploited and
that wasn't a big surprise because in
the 1930s the person who founded the the
Fisheries Service reported that haddock
was over exploited so this wasn't new
results it just took 70 years to
implement regulations again you know
it's nice to feel good about your job
but you know there was it I happen to be
in the job at the time when those
political forces were in the right place
and since then there's been increasing
difficulties as well but it's been
carried forward by Pat Cargill who's
done an extraordinary job of trying to
maintain that recovery and has been
vilified for it to an incredible extent
in addition to being hung in effigy for
sea scallops the recovery was faster
because they have a really nice feature
when you close an area they don't swim
they just kind of lie on the bottom like
a rock and grow really really fast until
you allow somebody to catch them so the
recovery of this population was
remarkable in the recovery and price
product quality and revenue to the fleet
also was fairly remarkable even though
fuel costs and some other costs
increased at the time because in 1994
they were making 10 to 14 day trips now
they can do the same for a better value
product in three days it's worth an
awful lot more its larger scallops and
three days cost you a lot less than 14
days so you know a fairly
straightforward result these people are
still bitterly complaining that it's not
you know but if you let them alone they
could go back out there and make a whole
lot more money even by hammering the
stock down again even though they've
made quite a lot of money by this
recovery why is that well because it's
still a resource that's out of sight and
out of mind to most people and they're
right they could make an awful lot of
money in a short term retire do
something else and that's correct so the
political battle doesn't end just
because you've shown proof of concept
I'm not trying to depress you that's
just the way it goes let's get this and
finally I'm going to talk briefly about
an effort that CI is engaged in to try
to actually understand that full chain
of theory of change from ecosystem
health to ecosystem services to human
well-being and we're beginning to
construct an ocean health index with the
partners that you see here that can be
scaled as I described before whoops from
an ecosystem out to a global scale
analysis and it's instead of basing it
on what we think should be in the ocean
we'd based it around a set of societal
goals so food provisioning services
subsistence harvest and the things that
you see here are at least nominally
fairly straightforward societal goals we
chara measure of health as opposed to
deciding what we want the ecosystem to
look like and the idea then is you try
to measure these in a fairly complete
way with a set of indices that are
become synthetic so you end up with a
number for food provisioning a number
for subsistence harvest or clean water
at whatever scale you're working out and
you can measure progress through time
now there's a number of really big
challenges there one of them is you need
to get down to the shortlist as I
described before a second one is it
can't just be current status so actually
it's status trend sustainability and
resilience to change is a component of
each part of the index it has to be
fully transparent transparent and people
have to accept that the societal goals
in fact are reasonable goals regardless
of how they weight them one to the other
so then you've got this index the real
worry is either it never changes so it's
like the threat level is orange in an
airport it's been orange for ten years
it doesn't tell you anything nobody
knows what to do with the answer so you
have to avoid that you want something
that is responsive but you also want
something that people can actually drill
down to the scale at which they are
working or for the goal that they most
care about so ultimately we think that's
possible we'll release it in the new
year for seafood for the whole set of
goals where you can actually go into a
website and look for a global analysis
at how well do we think different areas
of the ocean are doing for each of the
ten goals why is that the case and what
actions might result in a change in in
that ocean health so going back directly
to that theory of change it can't be
just about fisheries because fisheries
are not the measure of ocean health they
might get me yelled at a lot but there's
lots of other things that go on in the
ocean so trying to now have an
integrated index of whether in fact
we're providing ecosystem services is a
pretty near-term goal at CI and I've
talked a little bit too long so I think
I'm going to stop there
thank you and hope there's some
questions